and before we let you go to of course
Dana said that he doesn't want you to
fight Kirby but what do you want to
fight again uh yeah I took that the
thing is I'm at this point at man I have
a when when I train when I train I feel
very confident feel strong feel feel
very great I feel better than when I was
25 but at some time I heard a lot of BS
stuff and things is like I'm and I'm
like do I really want to go back into
that circle so I'm at this point I'm
think I'm gonna take the early days
think about it and see what's gonna
happen you might not want to worry with
politics of UFC you know exactly I
understand have a business to run but if
it's to go back and and run for another
like title reign because they have a
business can I go back fight for a title
then you fight for a title you have to
keep the belt defended and they had it
and I don't wanna make del dole division
on on the whole what did you think of
the Tino and Chuck fight because that's
I mean people left that fight going on
fine i watch it but yeah they I think
Chuck Chuck Chuck will always be
remembered as an incredible fighter that
he was once where but now he's gone it's
normal every there's something there's
something that there's an opponent that
nobody can beat it's time nobody can
beat time even burner up kids one of my
favorite boxer he did it until he almost
you think I'm out of the ring right yeah
he was like 49 other he went 5150 but he
can't knocked out now yet to stop you
know what I mean you there's a point
that you can you just can't do it man in
and then it's normal that's the way life
goes you know what I mean yeah I'm 37
you know like I feel great you know what
I mean it's only what age you have I
believe it's the window you know I've
started doing it when I was 19 years old
why that my window was is very long
right but if you don't start until
you're in your late 20s or something
you don't want the sport to retire you
you want to retire from the sport and
you guys always one of my goal maybe
maybe the sport retired Chuck officially
you think I don't like to talk about
like the guy I I hope I like truck I I
hope you will not go back you know what
I mean
I remember Chuck as the dominant
champion that he once where you know I
don't want to remember Chuck as that guy
like oh man do you see he came back and
it was true it was not you know what I
mean if you watch Ali fight like a Larry
Holmes you don't want that you don't
want that you want to go but go out on
top and that's how are you that's how we
should remember Chuck like that it's the
best thing Mike Tyson ever did it's just
he realized in that fight when he lost
he's like I'm done yeah he's like I
can't do this [ __ ] anymore
yeah go do one-man shows and whatnot
Tyson did point to his pony goes like I
know when I lose to a guy like this I'm
finished said that later